d'interdiction public il n'en sera pas
question ce week-end est derrière cette
porte se trouvent un trésor
plus de cinquante trois mille ouvrages
spécialisés accessible aux personnels
les chercheurs le service des ressources
documentaires recèle à la fois des
pièces d'archivés des documents des
cartes des mémoires de fouilles des
ouvrages commentée par leurs auteurs
mais aussi des ouvrages très anciens
nous avons des ouvrages du 16ème 17ème
siècle ce samedi elle va dévoiler un peu
de son histoire de l'émergence de
l'archéologie le travail d'érudits
locaux comme paul guégan saint germanois
ils attaquent heures après de de
naviguer dans tout le département donc à
l'époque l'acte un ancien département de
seine et oise pour recenser les vestiges
matériel archéologique et qu'il dessine
il avait un talent pour en faire une
énorme monographique n'a jamais été
publié autres lieux inédits la salle 16
du musée fermé au public depuis 2018
pour travaux elle révélera les enjeux du
chantier des collections comme celle de
la mosaïque de saint romain en gal
c'est aussi l'occasion d'expliquer les
métiers de la conservation les coulisses
du musée ce qu'on fait quand on est
conservateur du patrimoine quand on est
assistant de conservation le travail
qu'on mène à la fois sur les collections
sur les restaurations sur l'histoire des
lieux puisque on a beaucoup travaillé
ces derniers mois sur la muséographie
cette visite inédite s'inscrivent dans
le programme des journées européennes
d'archéologie le musée participe pour la
4e année c'est ici que ce que se tient
le village des savoir-faire franciliens
et donc qui permet d'accueillir
différents professionnels de diverses
institutions de l'archéologie que ce
soit à l'archéologie de terrain
l'archéologie de laboratoire ou encore
l'archéologie en musée une édition à la
saveur particulière pour les équipes
après une réouverture le 19 mai dernier
pour découvrir les coulisses du musée
une inscription est obligatoire